and thank you for joining us at 11 i'm
denise valdez and i'm brian loftis our
top story tonight the community coming
together for a candlelight vigil
honoring 31 year old benjamin black he
was hit and killed in the north valley
this weekend madison kimbrough joins us
live near 215 and north fifth street
with this story
yeah this is where ben black lost his
life you can take a look as you can
still see the marks on the road and
tonight candles and flowers were left in
his honor
for this to happen you know you know has
a little son and a little daughter on
the way and
for this to be you know
life to be pulled out from everybody you
know
it's just a tragic situation ben's uncle
heartbroken like the rest of his family
after news that his nephew 31 year old
benjamin black was killed riding his
bike in the thule springs community
sunday morning by a speeding black suv a
community he helped create as he worked
for the home building company kb home
resident elena santos saying after
seeing what happened to ben she fears
for her own son who rides his bike up
and down the street frequently no matter
what time of day you come out in the
morning might be like seven or eight
o'clock when my son is literally having
to cross the street to go to his bus
stop there are cars literally flying
through here there's times like ten ten
eleven o'clock at night we can be laying
in a bed and it sounds like literally
people are out here drag racing ben's
uncle ken furthering that notion that
people need to drive the speed limit and
be extra aware of their surroundings so
that another life doesn't get taken in
the process please everybody slow down
that's all i can say
please
kb homes shared a statement with us
regarding ben's passing saying in part
this tragic loss will be felt by all as
his lust for life and appreciation for
his family friends and colleagues will
be missed we of course have a link to
his gofundme page up on our website
reporting in north las vegas madison
kimbrough live local now